>> Welcome everyone.
My name is Mark Polleger and welcome to the
Authors@Google program.
And today we have with us photographer Michael
Clark, who's an action
and sports shooter.
And I came across him first during my days
at Adobe working with some
of the digital imagining teams there.
And he sort of came to my attention and started
working with some of
the product teams there, shooting example
photographs and talking about
sort of the technique and workflow using products.
And over the years, I sort of kept track of
him.
And he's been teaching workshops, doing a
lot of advertising shooting
and some of his own personal work.
And I thought that given the extreme interest
here at Google in the
photography community, and sort of not only
the substance of the
pictures but also the interest in how they
are captured -- particularly
for some of the more challenging shoots like
Michael does -- that he
would be a great speaker to come here and
talk to us about his work and
his techniques.
So with that, Michael Clark.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL CLARK: Thank you for having me.
Yes, my name is Michael Clark.
Thank you to Mark for bringing me out.
And thank you to all of you for coming out
to see me today give this
talk.
And above and beyond that, thank you for all
the work you guys do here
because you guys get me about half of my work
these days, through my
website, that I've had several assignments,
some of which I'll show the
work from, that came to me because I had my,
you know, search engine
optimization done for adventure photography
and people found me on
Google.
And somehow, luckily I show up in the top
one or two for adventure
photography in most categories and thank you.
Your work goes far beyond just the stuff you
guys do here.
So that's awesome.
And actually the book that I have also came
to me through you guys.
The photo editor, or the editor, actually,
at the publisher was doing
searches on adventure photographers and actually
seen my work in
climbing magazines years and years ago.
But he basically looked at 30, 40, 50 adventure
photographers and their
work and trying to figure out who he should
pitch the book to first.
And he looked at my website and found me through
Google.
And because of the number of images that I
had in various different
sports, chose me as the guy to go through,
and also because of my
newsletter, which goes out four times a year,
which is basically like a
little PDF magazine.
He decided to pitch it to me first and I accepted
it.
So that's how the book came to fruition.
I'll talk a little bit more about that as
we get going.
But the book is Digital Masters: Adventure
Photography, Capturing the
World of Outdoor Sports.
And it's been out since, I think, just after
Thanksgiving.
But again, thanks for having me out here.
It's a beautiful campus you guys have here.
It sounds like a fun place to work.
So about me: I did not study photography.
I studied to be a physicist and worked for
about a year after I went to
school at UT Austin.
I specialized in solid state physics, so I
actually kind of worked on
technology for -- for CCD chips before it
really started being used in
digital cameras en masse.
And then in my -- in grad school, I basically
started rock climbing.
And while I was taking grad school courses,
started rock climbing and
that got me into the outdoors and I was totally
obsessed.
It's kind of like surfing, once you start,
that's all you want to do.
So I schemed my way into a two-year long set
of travels, quit my job,
and headed off with my camera in tow, just
because I knew we were going
to be all these crazy cool places.
And through that process of those two years,
I decided to try
photography.
And that's kind of how I got into this.
And I haven't really looked back.
I've been a pro photographer for 14 years
now, mostly specializing in
adventure sports.
When I started out, it was mostly rock climbing
-- and I'll just let
you know, the colors on that screen are better
than this screen, more
accurate at least, but we did calibrate the
monitor or the LCD
projectors.
So I've been all over the world shooting rock
climbing.
For the first four years or so, that was pretty
much all I shot was
rock climbing because that was my one main
passion.
And the other reason being that I could really
-- I could make a living
of sorts, not a great living, but just shooting
rock climbing because
there weren't that many rock climbing photographers
in the world.
Basically because the skills you need to shoot
rock climbing, to get
above the climbers, you needed the climbing
skills and the photography
skills to put it all together.
And there's not that many people in the world,
or at least there
weren't at that point, that were willing to
work that hard to do that
stuff.
This is shot that's in Mexico at a place called
Potrero Chico.
And we're 600 feet off the deck, it took about
five hours to get into
position for this shot.
But it's been used by a bunch of companies
like Black Diamond who makes
climbing gear and stuff like that.
And after the four years or so -- this is
actually an article that
Nikon World put up in their magazine about
me and my work.
It's just showing a usage of that picture.
And this is actually -- well, going back,
this is me at work.
This is that same wall, actually, where that
last picture was taken the
one of the woman here.
I'm photographing her husband on a route just
next to it.
And it took us all day to get up there.
I'm carrying a lot of camera gear as you can
see.
Way more than I would now because I've got
some huge lens there, 80-
200 and a bag full of other stuff.
And that's mostly because we were on the wall
so long.
And I'm hanging from a static line that we
fixed before he started
climbing, so that I could -- didn't have to
climb because I can't
really climb and photograph.
So I'm hanging from these mechanical ascenders
where you slide them up
and they don't pull down, so I can totally
let go and manipulate the
camera.
And I just go up the rope with them, and I've
got these things called
etriers.
They are little webbing ladders so I do this
funky motion and ascend
the fix line, even if I'm hanging in space
and not even touching the
wall.
So this is a casual day, out there shooting
rock climbing.
I wear the knee pads, too, just because the
knee pads help preserve
clothing.
And I've learned that over the years.
Then you can lean into the wall really close
and not have to worry
about scraping yourself up.
But -- it's a lot of work shooting rock climbing.
It's definitely an incredible amount of work.
This is an article that came out in Outdoor
Photographer like eight or
nine years ago, but it's just a good example
of what it's like for some
of my shoots.
This is also one of the coolest assignments
I've ever done.
This was an assignment in Majorca, Spain,
for Men's Journal magazine.
This is all just kind of a little background
for you guys before we
start talking about specifics on the images
and how I made them.
This is a climber named Chris Sharma, who
is probably the strongest
climber in the world these days.
Super great guy.
This is a kind of a relatively new sport called
deep water soloing.
And it started here in Majorca, Spain -- well,
actually it started in
England 30 years ago, but nobody really got
into it because it was a
little nutty back then in the cold waters
off England's coast.
But in Spain the water's a little warmer,
we do this in late summer,
early fall, and basically they climb above
the ocean with no ropes.
And nobody had ever been there.
A friend of mine Toni Lamprecht was one of
the guys who found this
climbing on Majorca and called me up and said,
"Mike, we got to go do
something here because it's just crazy and
it's beautiful."
It's like the Blue Lagoon, the water is crystal
clear, even those it
looks black in this image, that's the film.
On this route, it had been raining for five
of the ten days we were
there.
And I was kind of freaking out because the
magazine wanted a double
page spread.
And this is the double page spread that they
actually used, and I knew
this was the perfect spot.
And so one morning the sun came up and I asked
Chris to go out there.
And we went out and he hung off this hold
for like 30 minutes, 3 times
in a row.
This is the biggest hold on the climb.
You know -- and he could -- and it's like
wrap your hand over thing.
He could hang off this thing all day if he
had to.
Every other hold on the climb is like super
tiny micro hold.
So we did this little, you know, pose down
and shoot, that ended up
being in the double page spread.
And there's also -- this is another climb
that we shot there where they
actually fell onto the water.
He's 70 feet above the water.
And there's -- granted there's also like ten-foot
waves rolling in
underneath him.
So at this point I'm like five feet away from
him.
I'm shouting and he can't even hear me because
it's so deafening with
the waves crashing against the water.
So in this shot, the thing he has to do, he's
holding on to two these
holds, which he can barely hold on to, and
this wall also overhangs by
about 30 degrees and he has to jump five feet
-- there's a big hold up
at the top there you can see.
It's so foreshortened because I'm straight
above him but it's an
all-points release, where you basically kick
off, everything goes, and
you've got to reach for that hold.
He didn't make it.
[LAUGHTER]
He took a 70-footer, and I've got a whole
series of pictures with his
dreads flying around and his facial expressions
are priceless,
actually.
[LAUGHTER]
His eyeballs when he -- I saw him up top,
cause you can go around and
use your route and climb back to the top,
his eyeballs just looked like
he had gotten out of some massive car accident.
And he was kind of freaking out, but it was
beautiful.
And here's Chris Sharma doing the same route.
He fell the first time but he made it the
second time.
And it's one of those super classic routes
in that area.
It's an ad for prAna, which is down the way
here in California they
make climbing clothing and yoga clothing.
So rock climbing is definitely in my blood.
Since I started out as a rock climber and
it's still one of my big
passions.
But I needed to expand my horizons a bit and
shoot something besides
just rock climbing.
So I started shooting mountain biking.
And this is an image I came -- or I shot for
Adobe, actually, when I
was shooting for Adobe Lightroom when they
came out with that four or
five years ago.
This is in Moab. And he is jumping off this.
It's like a 35-foot drop, and yes, he does
land here.
And it is rock.
So there's no room for error.
And this is a pretty casual drop for these
guys.
This is not a big deal.
He did it like, I don't know, eight or nine
times.
We had three riders doing this thing for a
couple hours.
I photograph this same rider Ryon Reed, great
guy, doing 50- to 60-foot
drops.
And there's some riders who have done close
to a hundred.
But I don't think anybody has actually landed
a hundred.
I think the biggest one is 60 or 70 if they've
landed.
I also started shooting white water kayaking,
which is a great sport to
shoot because it's just -- it's crazy.
Everything's moving fast.
It's actually a really good test for cameras'
auto focus because
everything is random all over the place.
There's no linear lines that these guys are
taking because they're
being pushed everywhere.
And then I also started shooting surfing,
actually, just a few years
ago.
This is, uh, Pipeline off the North Shore
of Oahu.
And interesting story with this is that I
-- started shooting surfing
because of this book.
Living -- I live in Santa Fe, New Mexico,
and I travel six to
seven months out of the year.
I'm not really traveling for surfing because
I don't live anywhere near
an ocean.
But for the book, we needed some surfing pictures.
And I ended up calling a guy named Brian Bielmann,
who is the like the
godfather of surf photography, great photographer.
He's been doing it for 25, 30 years on the
North Shore and all over the
world.
And he invited me out to shoot big wave surfing.
I basically had a tutorial from one of the
best surfing photographers
in the world and that was -- he's a really
good friend now.
It's a great honor to be able to do that through
the book.
>> Is the picture taken from the shore?
MICHAEL CLARK: This is from shore.
I have yet to swim in the ocean.
There's some -- definitely some other pictures
in this show from just a
couple months ago.
The Eddie Aikau when they had the biggest
waves roll through in the
last 40 years, which I'll show those later
but, using like a 500 or 600
millimeter lens, huge lenses.
And I also shoot some lifestyle stuff.
Images that are kind of, you know, the in-between
moments or less
extreme, one could say.
They sell a lot better, actually, in some
respects.
Backpacking, you know.
A lot of landscape stuff as well.
This is shot just above Santa Fe, it's called
the Tesuque Basin, late
afternoon one day.
Just getting out of the office, went up there
and shot some pictures
and ended up being one of the best landscape
pictures I've ever taken
probably.
This is Canyonlands in Utah.
Landscape pictures don't sell so much but
they're fun to take.
And they definitely fill in the details of
the moment and where you're
at.
Another lifestyle shot of mountain biking.
This one's on the Wasatch Crest near Salt
Lake City.
Beautiful trail, super, casual.
And then also -- here's another lifestyle
shot with yoga.
Most of my work is commercial or editorial,
so I'm shooting for
magazines or I'm shooting for corporate clients
like, you know, Nikon
and Nike, Adobe, whoever else, Patagonia.
And some of my work is stock.
So I shoot for a stock agency like Getty Images
or somebody like that.
And this was shot for stock, though it ended
up being used by
Patagonia.
Just went out with a yoga instructor to White
Sands, New Mexico, and
the story behind this image is we got really
lucky with the weather.
And the clouds, obviously.
Little did we know -- this was shot the night
we got there.
We showed up late afternoon, shot for two
hours and then we were going
to sleep and then shoot in the morning at
sunrise was the plan.
Well, little do we know these clouds were
bringing in some massive dust
storm.
And we didn't sleep a wink that night.
It was like a whiteout with white snow.
It was crazy, just, we had sand caked in our
eyes, everywhere.
And it was -- it was kind of a horrific night.
But -- the models were good to go the next
morning, even though nobody
slept and it was miserable.
They got up and kept working for us, so that
was great.
I also do a little bit of portraiture now.
And this is my friend Nico Danan, he's a French
free-diver. And he
had just gotten out of the water at this point,
diving a hundred feet,
I think, to the bottom of this freshwater
hole, to the very bottom.
And held his breath for about five or six
minutes.
And we did these portraits in the men's bathroom
entranceway.
For me, I don't really -- I don't have a studio.
So I improvise wherever I go and I take the
lights with me.
And I took a four-foot white background.
And it was kind of windy that day.
And this is out on this -- this is in New
Mexico.
And you don't think of there being that much
water in New Mexico, so
the only place we could find out of the wind
to set up the background
and the lights was in the entranceway of the
men's bathroom which was
only like six by ten feet.
So we just stacked ourselves in there.
And I told him as soon as they get out, come
on over and he still had
water dripping off his face.
I do a lot of these black and white on white
portraits these days just
because they're really intense and interesting.
And also I tend to shoot just my own personal
work, whatever kind of
grabs me.
This shot was taken at the Albuquerque Balloon
Fiesta, which is the
world's largest balloon fiesta.
There's like thousands of balloons taking
off every day.
And I had seen a shot somewhat like this with
some figures, you know,
on the outside of the balloon.
And I thought that's a cool idea.
I want to see if I could do something with
that or replicate it.
So I basically looked over the balloon grounds
because there were six
or seven balloons filling up at that point
and saw a bright one,
because I knew I wanted really bright colors.
And I just walked over to the guy started,
you know, befriending him
and then said, "Hey, can I get in your balloon
and just shoot some
pictures from the inside?"
Hoping that something would happen and I was
just about to ask him if
he could send a some people around, because
all the people have to do
is stand right next to the balloon.
And before I could even open my mouth, part
of his crew had gone under
and they were pushing the sides of the balloon
up because it helps it
fill up with air faster and poof it out and
I saw that I just started
snapping away and I couldn't believe my luck.
And it's definitely one of my best pictures,
I think, because it speaks
on a lot more levels than just ballooning
or people or whatever.
I'll go more into that here a little bit later.
One of the assignments I had recently just
last fall was Red Bull and
this guy Danny MacAskill, who is one of the
superstars of YouTube.
This guy went from working in a bike store
to two weeks later being a
full-time sponsored athlete with Red Bull
and all kinds of people
getting film for a Volkswagen commercial.
He's this -- he's this Scottish guy.
He's 22, 23.
Um, he's been riding his bike all his life.
And he does these crazy tricks and I'm sure
many of you have seen his
video riding the fence post and doing all
kinds of wild stuff.
And so Red Bull called me out to shoot him
and we landed in San Diego.
And we went out scouting to find stuff for
him to do and we saw these
rings by the airport and he was like, "Oh,
yeah I can do a back flip
off this thing. No problem."
So the next day, this is at the end of the
day, we went and shot this
and it took him 5 or 6 tries to get it on
because as you can tell it's
not flat.
We had to step up a little bag, he has to
hop onto this thing.
Super technical, just to do that.
I was really impressed he could pull that
off.
And cops rolled by.
We had been chased by the cops all day on
this shoot.
So a cop rolled by and just smiled at us and
gave us the thumbs up and
we're like all right.
We were ready to run at that point.
But, anyway.
The point of this picture.
I like this picture a lot.
This is one of my favorite pictures from the
shoot.
But this is the one that has a lot more impact.
And for you photographers, the note here is
get close.
You know, I think Robert Capa, famous photographer
from D-Day said, "if
your pictures aren't good enough, then you're
not close enough."
And definitely one of my mottos is get in
close with the wide angle
lens.
This is a fisheye lens, and I'm pretty much
laying on the ground.
I mean the tip of my camera is like right
here on the ring, pointing
up.
And it sees everything in the plane of the
camera so I don't really
have to worry about focus or anything like
that I just compose the
image.
And bam.
I just got to wait for the timing.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL CLARK: Exactly.
Well, he fell like six or seven times which
those were pretty good
pictures, too.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL CLARK: No.
Because he was going the opposite way, so
he would come in from this
side, go up, and then come down.
Um, which was great.
I mean, he did it probably ten times for the
camera.
And at that point, we thought, okay, the light
is not that bad.
We don't want him to get hurt, so we'll just
move on to the next thing.
Here's another shot from that day, and I was
telling this story earlier
over lunch, but this is him on an aircraft
carrier, the USS Midway, in
San Diego Harbor.
And the story behind this is that we'd got
on the ship, we only had an
hour.
And you know, as soon as we got on the ship
and told him what we wanted
to do the guy was like, no.
You can't do anything.
So I was like, it would be great if we can
get him to, you know, do a
back flip off the wings one of the planes
on the aircraft carrier [LAUGHTER] and
that was immediately axed that was just like
no.
That's going to injure the plane.
So we doing just ail kinds of, just have him
sit on the deck, nothing
that exciting down on the deck, and we look
up and he see these two
boxes up here.
And Danny's like, "Hey, can I just go up there
and stand on one of those
boxes with my bike?"
And so the guy from the museums like sure,
okay.
That won't be that big of a deal.
And I'm sitting -- you know, I'm 60 feet below
on the deck here
shooting up because I wanted a clean background
with like, I think I
was shooting with like a 70-200 millimeter
lens.
So he goes up there and the director goes
up there, the director of
the museum and me and the art director from
Red Bull are standing down
there.
And he stands up on the box and then, you
know, the guys are like okay
you're up on the box.
And Danny just pops a wheelie, and this is
60-foot -- this box is only
like 3 or 4-feet wide and there's a 60-foot
drop right in front of him.
And Danny's just looking over at the director
saying, "You know, I'm
more comfortable on my bike than I am on my
own two feet." And then he
immediately -- he pops to the other box.
So he started on this one, then popped to
this one.
And then you know just kind of did these little
up and down movements
and then popped back and then jumped off the
back of the box onto this
deck.
And the guy was standing right here.
And he didn't really say anything to that.
He's like okay.
And then as soon as the art director from
Red Bull saw this, she's like
oh, he needs a Red Bull T-shirt or something
because we couldn't see
the branding, which was perfect.
Because it was so complicated to get up here,
the director had to go
down to help her find her way up.
And in lieu of that, that's when Danny just
went nuts and started doing
all kinds of tricks off the stuff [LAUGHTER]
that nobody could see
except for me and him and this is one of the
pictures.
And then the director came back, they put
on a T-shirt and he just did
some quick little things, then we were quickly
escorted off the ship
after this.
[LAUGHTER]
But -- and there are so many other exciting
things that I photograph.
This is a shot I did with the Henry Search
and one rescue or -- Henry 1
Search and Rescue Team up in the Santa Rosa,
California.
These guys are unbelievable.
One of the best search and rescue teams in
the United States, if not
the world.
They do ocean rescues, cliff rescues.
And this is an assignment for Men's Fitness
magazine, that where
basically for three days, I flew with these
guys and I hung like a
hundred feet off the helicopter flying over
the ocean.
I got to, you know, do cliff rescues with
them where I was hanging
underneath the person they were rescuing.
All kinds of stuff like that.
There's a whole series of pictures on my website
about this.
So I get to have a lot of fun on some assignments,
some assignments are
quite a bit more miserable than this but we'll
show those here in a
bit.
Now for photo enthusiasts, we'll just talk
about the gear real quick.
This is a composite shot I did for the book,
that's like a two-page
spread in the book, and everything's is labelled
so you can tell what
it is.
This is kind of my complete kit except for
the fact that there's no
lighting equipment in here except for the
small strobes.
All of this doesn't go anywhere with me.
I don't own a 600.
I rent a 600 when I do surfing photography
because it's a really
expensive lens I wouldn't use that often.
So, you know, I'm using mostly digital cameras
these days.
I have Nikon equipment.
I've been using it for 20 years, so I just
stick with what I know.
I still shoot with a Hasselblad every once
in a while.
I still like film.
But everything becomes digital these days
at some point, so it's just
easier to shoot it digitally and not have
to worry about scanning the
film unless I'm going for a certain look.
This is generally how I carry my gear in a
big backpack, at least for
the cameras themselves.
I'll have a lighting kit going, which I'll
show you that here in just a
second.
This bag pretty much goes to the point where
I'm going, and then I end
up breaking it down into smaller bags, where
I can actually carry them.
So this would be what I would take on a rock
climbing shoot.
It's like a small top-loader bag that I can
either wear on my chest or
around my waist and maybe one or two lenses.
And for most of my stuff, I carry multiple
cameras, but I've got so
much other stuff like climbing gear or outdoor
gear to keep me safe and
not freezing to death that I can't carry too
much camera gear.
This would be a skiing setup.
I would wear that chest on my pouch -- or
that pouch on my chest.
[LAUGHTER]
That would be hard.
And one or two lenses.
And for like, you know, mountain biking, I
would take this just to have
different -- I have like a whole plethora
of bags.
I'm the Imelda Marcos of bags.
I have 20 or 30 of these different things
depending on the sport.
This would be like the backpacking setup.
So just whatever works.
This is my sea kayaking setup because I use
one of these underwater
housings just to keep my cameras from getting
destroyed.
And this is my adventure racing setup.
And I actually I use the smaller pro cameras
so I can take the grip on
and off, which the grip allows me to have
a faster frame rate and
longer battery life.
So if I need eight frames a second, then I'll
put the grip on.
If I don't like for adventure racing, I take
it off and then I have
five frames a second on this camera.
This is just some miscellaneous climbing gear
I would take.
This is a very light amount of climbing gear.
And if you're shooting surfing from the water,
this would probably be
the set up you're using.
These are SPL housings.
They're not fully waterproof that far down,
they only go to about 25,
30 feet but you're not really diving with
these guys.
So it's got to be light so you actually thrust
it out of the water at
the last second when you're getting nailed
by a huge wave.
So lighting stuff.
I do a lot of artificial lighting with my
images just because I want to set
myself apart from the rest of the pack out
there shooting these days.
And it takes a lot more work, it slows down
the process, and it really
complicates things massively.
But the results can be spectacular.
So I have battery-powered stuff.
I have Elinchrom Rangers, which this is probably
a 20-pound setup with
one head and the battery and a few light modifiers.
I also use these little quadras that they
just came out with, where
this a 7- or 8-pound setup 400-watt seconds.
The ranger before, the other slide, this one
is 1100-watt seconds, so this
the more pop if I need more power.
400 here.
And the little strobes that come with your
camera, they're only like
100-watt seconds.
So these are quite a bit more powerful than
those guys so they're not
and they're a lot heavier as well.
Then I use all kinds of light modifiers with
them just to soften light
or shape it or mold it how I want it to look.
The other thing, are cases I have Pelican
cases that I take my stuff
all over the place because I'm usually standing
on a beach or somewhere
and it might be raining and, you know, just
to protect the equipment,
which when you get on an airplane with three
or four of these things,
they'll look at you with a little strange
look like, how much? Okay.
Pull out your wallet.
So but the results can be quite different
than your average shot.
This shot has two strobes going at it with
grid spots which are like
little honeycomb foil things that go over
the strobe and direct the light
kind of like -- not like a laser but like
a spotlight to some degree a
diffuse spotlight and this is a cave Crystal
Cave in New Mexico.
It was 98 degrees this day in August and this
is Timmy Fairfield.
He's a world-class climber, this is a really
hard climb at 5.13, for
those of you who know climbing nomenclature
and he could barely even
hold on to the holds but he actually did the
route.
We're not posing here he's climbing the route.
I just made him climb that part of the lip
three or four times so that
I could get the shot.
And this shot specifically, I thought about
this shot, I'd been to the
location.
I'd scouted it.
I knew exactly what I would need.
I knew the route we wanted to get on.
I had it pretty much sketched out in my mind
before we got there and
then we got there and I hauled 200 pounds
worth of lighting gear up to
this cave to make it happen.
So this is, you know, and I was going for
this one shot, that was the
whole day.
It wasn't like just going out there and grabbing
a few shots.
>> Two hundred pounds of lighting gear?
MICHAEL CLARK: 200 pounds of lighting gear.
And this is one of those portraits I did for
that Men's Fitness article
with the Henry 1 guys up in Santa Rosa.
And this is a different shot than the rock
climbing shot in that we
basically had 30 minutes to set this up, get
this shot, and get out of
there because I was working with the sunset
and the background.
And there was only a space of 25 to 30 minutes
that would be there.
And then those guys, I had been shooting with
them all day and they
were kind of -- they were done, I could tell.
So I didn't want to like run them into the
ground here with the last
little portrait shoot.
But I think they were pretty psyched when
they saw the pictures.
So there's a bunch of strobes going off in
this point, in this shot.
There's two strobes laying on the ground with
red gels on them, which
gives that red look to the, you know, canopy
and everything.
There's the HUD display inside, the heads
up display, which has got
these green lights which is kind of casting
on them, on their jackets
especially.
And then I had little strobes pointing straight
at their face.
And at one point, I couldn't really get the
pilot on the -- on the
left's face to really show up, so I just handed
him a headlamp and told
him to hold the headlamp at his face.
So there's a lot of problem solving, you know,
super fast we had to get
this thing done.
And this is like one of the last shots I got
before we just stopped and
it worked out pretty well.
And sometimes you have no gear.
No lighting equipment and you have a headlamp.
And this was shot in Torres del Paine in Southern
Chile at four in the
morning.
I didn't have a tripod, so I just put the
camera on a rock.
And we took 50 shots while she stood there
and walked around.
With really minimal gear, you can get some
pretty amazing results if
you're just willing to work it.
Here's another shot that, if you first saw
this, you may just think
it's the end of the day sunlight.
And that's what I was trying to mimic here
just put the light where the
sun would be if the sun was still up, and
you know blast him from the
side with -- it's got a little orange gel
on the strobe.
And this is isn't that big of a jump.
It's just maybe 12-15 feet, even though it
looks really short from the
angle I'm at.
And I just had him do it five or six times
to get the right body
position and the timing had to be key too,
cause you only get one shot
with the strobes, you so can't blast off like
8 frames second and pick
the one you want.
Here's it's just one shot, so you kind of
have to nail the timing which
that's why it's great to work with pro athletes
because they can do the
same thing over and over and over and they
can put their body position
perfectly in alignment with where they were
before.
Or you can tell them do this or then they
can change how they're doing
their trick.
Some things aren't super crazy, you know,
I do a bunch of those pan
blur stuff as well, where it's slow shutter
speeds on the camera, and
then it's a strobe filling in and you get
these ghosting features.
And basically, I'm running with the camera
and have an assistant
running with the strobe, and you just click
off, you know, that's a
shot every few seconds as the strobe recycles.
And then, I mean, I think I probably shot
a hundred pictures just to
get this one picture.
And they're all -- you look at all the pictures
like, oh, this is crazy.
I remember I did this on the Adobe shoot,
we did a whole bunch of --
there should be a picture here doing that,
and the art director was just sitting there
like what are we doing?
And then I showed him a few of the pictures,
and he was like keep doing
that.
So it's kind of experimental but fun.
This is another more technically executed
version of that where I just
the camera is stationary this time and the
flash is too, and you just
have her ride by and you just catch it at
the right moment.
And you if you look close, she's actually
ghosted just a little bit but
she's sharp enough because the flash is sharpening
the person, the
flash is actually stopping the motion not
the camera.
Because the camera's set to a tenth of a second
and the duration of the
flash is creating a sharp, static image of
her in the frame.
And this is one of those pictures from the
Adobe assignment.
And my assistant was running with the full
strobe set up, it
probably weighed 15 pounds in sandals through
the bushes off the trail.
Luckily, she was okay.
But we did that like 250 times.
Here's another shot with just a headlamp.
I was in Canyonlands.
I had one camera, one lens with me.
My D700 and at 24-70, I taped it to a tree.
I didn't have a tripod, which it would have
been nice to have a tripod,
but -- and then I just walked out here.
It's like a 30-second exposure and, you know,
clicked on my headlamp,
shined it into the tent a little bit and then
kept walking out of the
frame.
And then the camera was just open to fill
in the stars behind it and
everything else.
And this is another one I shot for Adobe,
this is just popping over
like a five-foot ledge.
I'm actually tucked underneath this ledge
as tight as I can because
he's coming down like three or four inches
away from my face.
And then the strobe is being fired from above
the lip of this little
cave.
He landed on my feet at one point which was
not so much fun but worked
out for a good shot.
And here strobes is just kind of, you know,
just to mimic another
climber who is below this person.
I saw this happen where the other climber
looked up, as she was coiling
her rope on top of this little boulder.
And it lit her up and kind of separated her
from the sky so I mimicked
that action by just putting a strobe there
to make it brighter because
the strobe wasn't that bright.
So out in the field, you know, you use all
the tricks you can to get
the pictures to make them look the way it
feels while you're out there.
Like especially the mountain biking stuff,
sometimes if you just take a
straight picture, it doesn't feel as big as
that 20- or 30-foot cliff
felt when you look at, the awe of those guys
doing what they do.
So I use a lot of fisheye effects like this
image, where this is only 6
or 7 feet tall but just getting underneath
there and close in is a
great little effect.
Rock climbing one of the challenges is showing
how steep it looks and
giving that feeling to the person.
Generally that means being above the climber
which really helps out.
It's a lot more work because you have to get
above the climber but
sometimes you can shoot from the side.
Kayaking, it's the auto focus setting of your
camera blasting away as
much as you can.
Kayaking things are moving so fast it's hard
just to keep the person in
the frame if you're tight, and you want to
be semi-close.
If you're not that tight, then there's just
going to be a little dot on
a river.
So that can be a major challenge.
To overcome that usually what I do with my
camera -- and I think the
Canon cameras are the same -- they have like
a whole field of focus
points.
And I'll choose where I want the person to
be, you know, if I want her
to be in the lower right or the lower left
or wherever I want them to
be in the composition, I'll just the put the
point there and I'll plant
that on their head as they move.
And so that's how you can control the composition
as they move through
the frame.
And you know, I can see if it's working on
the back of my camera since
we're shooting digitally these days, so that's
kind of nice.
Mountain biking -- we'll do some questions
at the end here.
Mountain biking is kind of a similar thing
as well.
You just kind of put your points where you
want them to be in focus and
you know especially this trip, this is like
a little BMX jump which he
did like 10 or 12 times.
So I can kind of perfect the shot.
And every time I keep shooting, I'll get one
frame, okay, that's not
really working.
Let's try this, let's try something different.
And sometimes mountain biking you just got
show the pure speed with
like a big dust trail or something like that
this is up in Silverton.
And he's doing like 40, 50 miles an hour coming
down this downhill
track, just flying.
And this is a guy, this is, I can't remember
his name -- but these guys
hiked to the top of a 13,000-foot cliff across
from Silverton, no
trails.
Talus slope, got on their bikes, downhill
bikes rode straight down the
mountain.
The talus, you can actually see, this is a
big chunk of rock about the
size of his head coming down after him.
They rode straight down here, went out into
this grassy valley straight
down this valley out into here.
There were like maybe 12- to 15-foot wide
streams that -- with cliffs next to
them and they just jumped straight off the
cliff, over the streams,
down.
No trails anywhere.
These guys are amazing.
This is also the guy who jumped off the 100-foot
cliff and broke his
back.
And the doctor put two, I think it was fiberglass
rods, into his back
into his spine, and he -- and the doctor told
him that his spine was
stronger than it was before.
Bad news.
Because he still does this stuff and he walks
around with a cane, great
guy.
But they're doing some pretty amazing stuff.
Another great picture or story with this picture,
he's doing about
90 miles an hour right here.
It's -- this would be much better in video
but still frames, basically,
he dropped into a bowl above this and is arcing
up on this wall.
And there's a cave underneath him right here
that you can't see in the
shade and this is the top of the arc.
And he comes down, this little boulder right
here, shows like the foot
and a half place where the transition is smooth.
Everywhere else the transition is kind of
not smooth, so if he hits
there he's going to fly straight off the front
the bike and die
probably because he will hit his head impacting.
While -- he's not doing 90 here but he's doing
90 when he gets there
and then he goes up on to that thing and comes
back.
He found this place and was the first guy
to do this little wall ride.
And one of my other biking friends who I'd
shot a lot saw this was like
no way I'm not doing that.
That's totally nuts.
So we did this five times.
The fifth time he nearly stalled here and
would have fallen 80 feet,
and we stopped.
So a big part of my job is managing risk with
the athletes as well to
some degree or at least trying to talk them
out of stuff.
Actually did talk that guy out of something
else that would have been
really crazy.
Here's another one of the pan blur images.
Sometimes the conditions aren't so great.
This is in Alaska, up in the Ruth Glacier,
spent a month up there, saw
the sun maybe three days.
Didn't really do anything but sit in a tent.
Read the Brothers Karamazov, it was good.
And I'm going to skip along through a bunch
of different images here
real quick.
Sometimes the details are the best thing.
[PAUSE]
Also the lifestyle stuff is -- kind of shows
the background, you know.
This is a shot going into Indian Creek which,
you know, it's not that
unbelievable a shot.
But it's just driving in at the end of the
day after a long day of
climbing, the Balloon Fiesta again, some of
the mountain bikers,
surfing.
I'll quickly show some of these images from
the Eddie Aikau.
It's rare in a professional's life or any
photographer's life that
things line up so perfectly.
I planned this trip a month in advance and
had no clue if there would
be waves or not when I got to the North Shore
of Hawaii.
Two days after I was there, there were warnings
going off that the
biggest waves in 40 years were going to hit
the islands.
And they were warning everybody to evacuate
the coast line because they
thought houses would get ripped off the shore,
which a few of them were
damaged but nothing got ripped off luckily.
But as to turned out, they had the biggest
big wave surfing contest
that's ever been held.
And they had 50- to 60-foot waves.
This is Sunny Gonzalez under a 50-foot wave
at Waimea Bay.
The interesting thing is they were basically
free falling off the top
of the waves.
So you would -- and this isn't even that big
of a wave.
This is only 40 feet, for these guys.
So you'd free fall like 15 or 20 feet before
you even touched the wave
face.
And that was pretty amazing, these guys.
I mean, this is the who's who of surfing.
You got the Andy Irons, Bruce Irons, Kelly
Slater.
Everybody's there that's -- the whole crew.
And this is Greg Long who won it.
He caught like three 50- or 60-foot waves
right at the end of the day.
This is another pan blur from Pipeline, actually,
this is just up the
beach.
So but -- projects, this project came to me
-- it's the Wenger
Patagonia Expedition Race, came to me through
Google, through you guys.
They looked for adventure photographers.
They just typed in adventure photographers,
and my name came up number
two or three.
And the number one and two guys were there
at the event shooting with
me.
They picked the top three.
And it's the one of the longest, hardest races
in the world, up there
with the Tour de France, I would say, and
the Iditarod and a few of
those guys.
It is an adventure race.
So basically there's hiking, there's sea kayaking,
there's climbing on
ropes not like climbing -- rock climbing.
And there's also mountain biking which is
on roads down there because
there no single track.
And there's also dragging your boats over
islands, too, if you really
enjoy suffering.
So it's -- it's one of those suffer fest races,
where I haven't seen
human beings willingly put themselves through
this much pain ever.
These guys could go climb Everest three times
back to back and not even
sneeze, I have a feeling.
They're just -- they're superhuman.
Six hundred miles in ten days, no trails,
except for the roads for the
mountain biking and no maps.
In fact, actually, the maps are Google Earth
maps.
That's all they had, which were incredibly
detailed, but you know
that's pretty amazing when you're in the middle
of nowhere.
I mean, we're talking 300 or 400 miles from
anywhere.
And I'll just quickly tell this story, this
is last year, 2009, when I
was shooting the race.
I was with those guys in the trekking section
and a couple of the
teams, and we ended up on this fishing boat
in the Magellan Straits.
And we got on this boat, me and another photographer
and one of the
riders and we had been backpacking for three
days.
It had been raining sideways the entire time,
we were just -- we were
over it.
We were done.
And we were about to go hypothermic when this
boat pulled into the bay,
and we asked if we could stay on their boat
for a couple hours while
the race organizers sent us a boat.
What ended up happening is we were on the
boat for a day and a half
because the boat never showed up from the
race.
But it was one of the coolest things that's
ever happened in my career
because as soon as we got on the boat, we
realized these guys were a
National Geographic moment.
They were so interesting.
They were fishermen who fished for this stuff
called luga, which is
like red algae on the bottom of the ocean.
So this is the father and he worked with his
son.
And he would be under the water for 15 hours
every day, breathing
through a garden hose.
Just a garden hose -- not with the end chopped
off; attached to a
generator on the boat, which would stop every
once in a while.
And for lunch the next day, he asked us if
we wanted fresh king crab
and sea urchin.
We were like, yeah, for sure.
So he dove over the side, got some sea urchins,
came back with a bag
full of like 50 of them, we cracked them open.
Eating sea urchins on the boat with a little
lemon juice.
It was phenomenal.
And then he went back over and got this just
giant king crab, which we
ate.
And it will never get any better than that
for me, so I'll never have
king crab again.
And this is just one of the portraits I got
of him as he came up and
then Nikon World did an article on the whole
story.
But then portraits -- I shoot a lot of portraits
just because for
magazines, you need to be able to tell different
parts of the story.
Most of my portraits have something to do
with the outdoor world in
some respect.
And digital workflow.
I shot a big deal for Adobe three or four
years ago with Mark and those
guys, the crew there.
And through that, I wrote a book on basically
my entire digital
workflow which is available on my website.
It's not really a published book.
It's a PDF E-book but just shows my entire
workflow from the camera all
the way through to when I deliver the images
to the client.
Very interesting little book, a lot of people
love it.
Check it out on the website, if you want it.
The other thing I have and this is free stuff.
This is the marketing deal I started ten years
ago or more which gets
me many jobs, including the one I got with
Mark here at Adobe, and it's
basically a magazine.
It's a PDF document, anywhere from 15 to 20
pages, and in it includes
gear reviews, it has articles about my latest
assignments.
Here's one about the expedition race last
year.
It talks about all the gear I use.
It has little digital tips for photo editors.
It's something I send to photo editors and
it's got like 5,000 people,
I think now, that sign up for it and get it
whenever I get around to
writing it four times a year.
It includes a lot in that stuff the images,
special portfolios, and
stuff you can take home for yourself.
So when you guys are out there shooting, what
can you learn from an
adventure photographer?
If you haven't figured it out already, preparation
and planning.
Like if you're using strobes, you got to really
think about that stuff
and figure out how you're going to integrate
that into your shoot.
Improvising and problem-solving are always
good skills, and here at
Google, I'm sure you guys are great at that
stuff.
Transferring it your camera and that stuff
is just a matter of knowing
your camera.
Also, don't forget about the details, like,
look for those things that
aren't apparent at first, like the people's
hands, their feet, their
expressions.
Look for what they're doing and really get
in close.
I mean, you're probably shooting your friends
or they'll soon become
your friends, if you're shooting adventure-type
stuff.
And try to get in close and just crop things
out, so you can show
what's going on without showing the entire
scene.
And then also, I'd say master -- I mean, I'm
guessing you're all
shooting digital for the most part -- master
your digital workflow
because it's kind of sad to see a great image
kind of not be worked up
perfectly or not have a color-calibrated monitor,
this or that or
whatever.
So it doesn't kind of make it all the way
down the pipe to where it
could be.
Also helps if you're obsessed, and you work
crazy hard, which I'm sure
you guys have no problem with those.
Come early, stay late.
You know, after everybody started leaving
that's usually when the good
stuff starts happening or before everybody's
gotten there.
And set yourself up for success is the one
big thing I would say.
There's a National Geographic photographer
who used to say, who is Jim
Richardson, "If your images aren't that good,
put something more
exciting in front of the camera."
So it's pretty, well, you can tell from my
work, I go by that
philosophy.
I just find the craziest thing going on and
I can take pictures of it.
It's not that hard to get a great picture.
And that will definitely help.
And by setting yourself up for success I mean
go out when the light is
good.
Go out, you know, when you've got a good composition
set up because
you've scouted it out or something like that,
so that you know you can
get a good picture.
So you're just going out on the hope and a
prayer, it's going to hard
to get some decent pictures so a little forethought
and planning.
Anyway, thanks again for having me out.
It's been a pleasure and an honor to be here
with you guys.
Any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
>> So, um, we have -- so if you have any questions,
um -- say, please,
we have a mike over here or if you just want
to shout them and we can
repeat them up here with a little bit of time.
Make them good questions.
[PAUSE]
MICHAEL CLARK: Anyone?
>> So for stuff like for rock climbing where
some of it is just kind of in the moment,
how do you balance between actually setting
up a certain shot versus just trying to be
there and capture what happened?
MICHAEL CLARK: So the question is how do you
set up a rock climbing
shot and basically --
>> It's like the balance between setting up
a specific composition versus just capturing
what happened, like how do you balance that?
MICHAEL CLARK: How do you balance specific
action and capturing what
happens?
Um, it's always a little of both is the answer,
I guess.
Because you're setting up for one route is
basically what you're
setting up for, and then whatever -- it's
not like I'm shooting just
one section of that route, I'm going to shoot
the entire length of that
climb.
And I may not even know what the best picture
is that from route if
I've never seen it climbed before.
So what will happen is I'll usually -- I'll
just work my way up with
the climber and I'm pulling the rope up behind
me so that's it's not in
the picture.
And if I find a section that looks really
interesting from my angle
which is usually a body position or something
like that, then I'll just
have them climb that like five or six times
and then we'll move up.
I mean, the sad fact is that most rock climbing
photography is posed
because there's no other way to do it hardly
unless you're shooting
from the ground or somewhere else.
Or unless you're a phenomenal climber who
can climb as fast as the
climber is climbing with camera gear.
So does that answer your question?
Okay.
Sir?
>> What is your working relationship with
your, eh, models?
With the climbers and such?
Does somebody hire you for a shoot and then
you hire a climbers or does
somebody else do the whole thing or --
MICHAEL CLARK: It's a good question.
Mostly with climbing, they're all my friends
that I've, you know, known
for years, and either like say the North Face
would call me and they
want me to go out with a certain crew of people
who I already know or
the climbers are going somewhere, and then
I pitch the story to a
magazine or somebody.
So it kind of goes back and forth both ways
between the sponsor, the
climbers, me all talking at the same time
and sometimes I don't know
the climbers at all.
But I get introduced through other climbers
who say, oh, you should go
talk to this guy, he's a great climber.
You'll get some great images of him.
So it's just kind of random all over.
Any other questions?
[PAUSE]
>> Have you ever been in a situation, for
example, you're on a boat for a [INAUDIBLE]
and you didn't expect to be there, did you
ever run out of batteries or [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL CLARK: Um, I've nearly died a few
times --
[LAUGHTER]
I've nearly died a few times.
The question was have I ever, like, been in
a situation where I ran out
of batteries or something went wrong.
Just the question.
I've never run out of batteries.
I usually come with way more batteries than
I would ever need but I
have had some extremely close calls where
my rope nearly got cut.
Well, I was hanging from one strand of the
core out of seven, 300 feet
above the ground that was pretty exciting.
Yeah, I've had several.
I've been hit by falling rock.
So stuff has definitely gone wrong.
And I'm very lucky to be here.
Knock on wood.
But does that answer your question?
Yeah, okay.
>> Hi, one problem I've had is when trying
to focus on moving things
with one focus point, a lot of times it falls
through to the
background.
What do you do about that?
How do you sort of keep that from happening?
MICHAEL CLARK: Auto focus is tough.
Which cameras are you using?
>> D300.
MICHAEL CLARK: Okay.
I've got that camera.
It's a great camera.
Talking specifically to that camera, there's
dynamic focusing which you
can set up so that you have one point you
choose and then it uses
however many points you tell it to around
that to select the focus.
And using that, it usually can hold onto something
pretty well.
If you're using just one point as a static
focus, yeah, it definitely
with will go to the background.
There's a whole bunch of stuff which I talk
about in that little
digital workflow book on how to set up my
camera.
And Canon is a little different, I don't know
how the auto focus
settings are on that camera but there's different
ways to set up the
auto focus so it will work for certain sports.
And you just got to experiment because one
doesn't necessarily work for
the other sport but the dynamic focusing option
definitely works.
And I can talk to you more about that if you
want afterwards.
Anybody else?
And by the way, if you want to read that story
about the rope getting
cut, it's on my website.
I was on assignment for Climbing Magazine
and I called the magazine the
day after it happened because I pretty shaken
up obviously.
And they were like -- we don't need -- we
don't want a photographer to
die on assignment. It's never happened yet.
We don't need it to happen yet or now.
So it was pretty gripping.
Any other questions?
Go ahead.
>> What are your next projects?
MICHAEL CLARK: Next projects?
Well, immediately I'm going down to LA tomorrow
for some book signings,
but some more shoots for Red Bull, the Red
Bull Rampage is this fall.
I've got another few shoots for [INAUDIBLE]
and some other companies
here are coming up and editorial assignments.
I don't have any major epic adventure coming
up.
I was at Patagonia twice this year so I'm
kind of taking a little rest
at the moment but just little stuff here and
there.
Thanks for having me out guys.